Let's go next to our caller from the seven
eight five area code.
Who is calling today from seven, eight five.
Hi, David.
This is David.
And, uh, as I said, a quick question [inaudible]
you've had a few videos where you've shown
concern over, uh, Trump at his rallies where
they, uh, where he seems to either be high
or low.
You met other videos where you've looked at
perhaps, um, Sudafed, um, abuse, uh, uh, other
contestants from some of his shows have shown
concern about Adderall abuse and things like
that.
What I'm curious about is, um, how we can
get the, uh, mainstream media to, um, uh,
report on this or, or to, you know, use their
sources in the white house to, to uncover
some of this because other than outlets like
yours, it seems that no one's really looking
at this.
And related to that, you know, Trump has a
history of, of using prostitutes and other
sorts of things.
I just can't see that all of a sudden stopping
once he became president.
And, uh, it doesn't seem like, at least I
haven't heard anything about people looking
into that.
He's still using prostitutes during his presidency.
And I'll take my answer off the air.
Oh, all right.
Well, listen, I, uh, I don't know.
Uh, some people are looking into the Trump
health stuff.
I mean, we've seen, um, we've, we've seen
Thom Hartmann do an interview recently about,
uh, about that.
But I, I think the only way that it's really
going to break into the mainstream is if,
for example, we start to see democratic candidates
talk about it, that would push it into corporate
media, uh, and, and sort of the, the political
mainstream.
Um, if we have a mass campaign to, for example,
on Twitter, just constantly have tens of thousands
of people hammering on all of the primary
news anchors on CNN, Fox news, MSNBC, the
networks, et cetera.
It's going to take a lot of work to get it
into the mainstream unless something big happens
where there is something so obvious that it
can no longer be ignored like Trump during
a speech, you know, his, uh, shirt flies open
and, and bottles of pills fly out, right?
I mean, like on sort of something cartoonish.
I think it will take a lot for corporate media
to start talking
about it.